[music playing]
NARRATOR: Seti the first was the
father of our friend Ramesses
the Great.
Just like his son, he was a
hugely successful pharaoh.
But in father-son rivalry,
there's one category where
he wins hands down, his mummy.
Because Seti the
first boasts some
of the finest
mummification work in all
of ancient Egyptian history.
Mummification is an
incredible process
of drying out and
embalming the body
to preserve it, ready for
its journey to immortality
in the afterlife.
Key to it all was the
preparation of the body.
Typically, your brain is pulled
out through your nostrils
with an iron hook.
Next, all of your
major organs are
removed apart from the heart.
Ancient Egyptians believed this
was the center of your being.
These organs are then
preserved in special jars,
so they can be reunited with
their owner in the afterlife.
[music playing]
Your body is then covered in
a salt called natron and left
to dry for up to 40 days.
[music playing]
Finally, the now mummified
body is wrapped head
to foot in hundreds of meters
of linen bandages attached
with a glue, and magical spells
are cast to protect the mummy
and prepare it for safe
arrival in the afterlife.
But Seti's mummy is unusual.
His face is incredibly
well-preserved.
He looks almost
perfect, not what you
might expect from a body
over 3,000 years old.
But frankly, Seti's has had
quite a lot of work done.
Unlocking the secrets behind
Seti's youthful good looks
is professor of
radiology Sahar Saleem.
I always looked at his mummy
and I said, "This is no mummy.
This is a sleeping
beauty," and I've always
wondered, what was his secrets?
The secrets revealed to me that
the ancient Egyptians were very
efficient as plastic surgeons.
So was it really
plastic surgery?
Yeah.
And they actually placed
feathers around the nose
and the mouth, in this
region, in the cheeks,
and even in the temporal.
What does this tell you about
their ideas of ancient beauty
for men as well as for women?
The ancient Egyptian would
like to look like his gods.
There is something very,
very charismatic about him.
He was the most well-mummified
person from ancient Egypt
that I've ever looked at.
I love the way
you talk about him.
I bet you wish you'd met him.
Definitely.
We will meet one day.
Yeah, in the afterlife.
Brilliant.
Well, good luck.
[laughs]
NARRATOR: Egyptians
beautified Seti's mummy
to make sure it was in
the best possible shape
to travel to the afterlife.
Once there, Seti would need a
stunning home for all eternity.